meanwhile to this democrats are trying
to steamroll joe biden's 3.5 trillion
dollar socialist wish list through the
house and the senate all this week and
they're trying to sell it as a plan for
the future with things that really
matter get a pen
like three billion dollars towards tree
equity and 15 million dollars for senior
citizens with gender identity issues now
i spoke to south carolina senators tim
scott lindsey graham yesterday and they
raised some flags as the direction of
the bill listen
bringing and ushering in socialism in a
way that's going to be hard to unroute
it's hard to unscramble an egg and what
they're doing with this three and a half
trillion dollar package the content
rushes us towards socialism this is the
biggest threat to way our government
works and the biggest step towards
socialism in my lifetime
well uh but the real obstacle is pelosi
that pelosi is facing maybe from her own
party the democrats who are skeptical of
the plan they have some moderates and
those way to the left so pelosi decided
to take it to the media over the weekend
to voice her concerns
this will be paid for so when some say
oh well what about inflation it will be
paid for and that's the beauty of it
let's not talk about numbers that's in
dollars let's talk about values
okay i'm sorry for getting caught up in
the trillions it sounds like even pelosi
doesn't know who's paying for all of
this she's more concerned about values
not costs aren't we all but don't worry
mr speaker biden seems to have the
answer in a tweet he really assuaged me
and made me have a sensational afternoon
he said my build back better agenda cost
zero dollars and it adds zero dollars to
the national debt
what am i missing now democrats are in
the house already pushing through with
this narrative like congressman jayapal
listen to this
president biden also said something very
important the other day which is this is
a zero dollar bill because it's going to
be completely paid for
with taxes
my head is about to explode
nothing makes sense anymore here to save
me texas congressman dan crenshaw
congressman i didn't know a three
trillion dollar bill was free
it's not free nothing is free brian and
i'm sorry but i but i can't give you a
good explanation for this because there
isn't one and i'll tell you what it's
also well above three trillion dollars i
mean the new estimates on it based on
actually going through it in the budget
committee are almost four and a half
trillion dollars and there's only about
two trillion dollars in tax increases so
i know math is hard for democrats and
especially so for the ones who govern
but this math doesn't work out the other
really interesting thing about about
this is their lack of understanding
about basic economics so biden said it
costs zero dollars that's like saying
when i go buy a cup of coffee just
because i paid for it that it doesn't
cost anything but of course it costs
something
i think what this bill really boils down
to is straight-up bribery for the
progressive agenda for the progressive
activists and trying to bribe the
american people and tell you what
because of this bill you might need
those bribes because it's going to kill
your jobs and it's going to kill your
wages you know if you're in the energy
sector it's an estimated 90 000 jobs
lost because of the bills because of the
provisions that are in this bill and the
natural gas tax for instance not only
that but your electricity prices are
going to go up as a result and you're
not going to have reliable energy okay
just like the problems in california and
frankly that's what led to some of the
problems in texas there's a lot of bad
stuff in this i mean the corporate tax
increase will kill jobs not only that
but economists estimate it will also
reduce wages so this is bad on so many
fronts it'll lead to slower growth and
stagnation and inflation
which is just not something americans
need right now so there's two bills just
so everyone doesn't get confused there's
1.2 trillion that was handed to you guys
that the senate passed with 19
republicans voting for it so-called
bipartisan bill evidently there's 23
hard yeses among republicans in the
house for that but there's 45 hard no's
from the left-wing democrats where's the
1.2 trillion bipartisan plan and what
does dan crunch do what does dan
cranshaw do about that that's a really
good point to make so there's the
massive reconciliation package and
there's the infrastructure package now
the infrastructure package my problem
with the infrastructure package is that
it's simply too expensive the stuff
that's in there isn't that bad but i
think it's about three times more
expensive than it needs to be um and the
good news is the progressives aren't
going to let democrats pass that one
either
because look i think the last thing we
need after spending almost six trillion
dollars over the past year because of
covid relief is more spending all right
we need to rein it in do what works for
the economy do what promotes growth and
when you promote growth businesses
flourish they're hiring people and wages
increase you know where wages especially
increase for the bottom quintile of
earners that's proven under the trump
economy and
we could do it again again all joe biden
had to do to be successful was do
nothing but he can't help himself but
they're going to be raising taxes from
37 to 39 on the upper class they're
going to be taking the doubling the
capital gains tax they're going to take
the corporate tax rate from 21 to 28
maybe even higher
they're going to find a way to pay for
at least half of it with tax dollars
that usually go to grow the economy
congressman it's a scary time i hope
republicans can stand up for it because
it's not even about politics it's about
the future of the country thanks so much
thanks brian you got it hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else